welcome to exploring computing
today's video is about programming
so unless you programmed before this
whole programming process can seem quite
mysterious and very strange and very
unnatural
but there's actually a bunch of
different activities that we do that are
quite similar to programming in many
ways so i'm going to start off by
talking about a couple of these
so one activity that's quite analogous
to programming is
giving directions if somebody asks me
how to get to
san francisco international airport from
stanford
i would say get on sand hill road travel
east
until you hit the freeway get on to 280
north
switch to 380 east switch to 101 south
in the sfo lanes and you should hit the
airport
so i've given a series of instructions
and if the person who i've given the
instructions to follows the instructions
properly they should end up at
sfo another example is
cooking so here's the instructions for
making craft macaroni and cheese
you boil the water you stir in the
macaroni and cook for seven to eight
minutes
you drain you add butter milk and cheese
mix
and then you mix well so again
uh for both these tasks we are giving
by the way that's maddie sneezing if
you're wondering what's going on over
there
uh for both these tasks we've given a
number of directions
that should be carried out step by step
and they are to be carried out
in the order in which they're listed
that is important
and they are not to skip any of the
steps that actually turns out to be
important as well
um so if our instructions are good and
the user follows them explicitly
they should successfully fulfill the
task
that we've given instructions for so the
good news here is the computer will
always follow the instructions exactly
it turns out that
that's not always the case with humans
and just to give a rather
embarrassing example one of the
first things i remember trying to cook
was craft macaroni and cheese
and i skipped one of the steps which was
the drain step
and i ended up with kraft macaroni and
cheese soup
it was pretty disgusting and this would
be an amusing tale if i were like five
at the time but i was actually in
college so
all right well that's not gonna happen
the computer if you tell the computer to
drain the macaronis
it will drain the macaronis
so uh another thing to keep in mind here
is
we've got so i've got my little program
here um so the computer as i said will
carry out the instructions in the order
listed
and it will execute them in the order in
which they're listed and it actually
turns out that last part is
kind of important and this is something
that i have found that
many new programmers don't pay a lot of
intention to that is
the order in which you list the
instructions for the computer
is often very important so if we look at
our little program here
i ask the computer to
ask the user for the temperature in
celsius i carry out my little celsius to
fahrenheit conversion and then i go
ahead and print out the
temperature in fahrenheit it has to
happen in this order if i reverse the
order of any one of these statements we
have a problem so in the bottom example
here
i have asked the user what the
temperature is in celsius
and i print with the temperatures in
fahrenheit and
then i calculate the temperature
fahrenheit that doesn't make sense so
in this case the ordering is very
important if i reorder these
it's not going to work and i do often
see students
just randomly reordering their
statements because it's not working they
figure if they just reorder them maybe
that'll fix things
you need to think carefully about what
the order is and why the statements are
in that order and put them logically in
the correct order
so in this particular example
we are converting a total number of
minutes to the number of
out hours and minutes and actually in
this particular case
the ordering of those first two
statements is not important if i
calculate the number of hours first
followed by the minutes or if i
calculate the minutes first spot by the
hours
that can actually go in either order
whereas that last statement the print
statement does have to happen
after the first two statements occur so
ordering is
often important but not always important
again the best way to work this out is
to think things through logically
what is each of these statements doing
is the order between this statement and
the next statement or this statement in
the previous statement is that important
or is that not important
okay as i suggested in the last lecture
there is this
edit debug cycle where i write or edit
my code
i try it out see if it works um
if it doesn't work i go back to writing
or editing the code
and i try it out again and i just keep
on repeating that process as long as
necessary
this is very similar to the process we
had for our html and css
and this is this process we will use for
python or for any other programming
language
the one area where i think
it's not that that this process falls
apart it is still the same process but
the one area where
the process with programming is harder
than the process with html and css
is that in html and css the results are
always visible that's one of the reasons
why i like
teaching html css first you load that up
on the web page and you can see what
went wrong
oh i thought i was only making you know
the title bold but i see the entire web
page is bold
i start thinking about what might make
the entire web page bold maybe i forgot
to end my bold tag
so in html and css the results are
always visible
with programming sometimes the results
are invisible and in particular the
intermediate results are often invisible
because
you recall from our previous discussion
we have these storage locations which
are for just variables
and we are storing our intermediate
results in these variables
we don't know what the variables are set
to
and uh in order to figure out you know
if if
if we start up a program and it works
great
but if we start for a program and it
doesn't work the question is why isn't
it working
and a lot of times the reason why it's
not working is our intermediate results
are wrong
and so how am i going to figure out what
the intermediate results are because
they're invisible well
as a professional programmer there are a
variety of different tools we can
apply to make the uh the invisible
results
visible but the easiest thing for
someone just starting out is to just use
a print statement so
you recall if i use a print statement it
is just going to print the value of
whatever's inside that print statement
out
onto the python
interpreter or the python shell and so
here let's say i've got this variable x
i don't know what x is doing it doesn't
seem to be working
i'm guessing that x is wrong but i'm not
really sure because i can't actually see
it
it's invisible what i do is i i add this
print
x statement into my code and again you
think about where where to put in your
code it's going to vary depending upon
which part of your code you're concerned
about but you know wherever i put in
print x
what's going to happen is the python
shell will print the value of x right
there and i'll i'll either be like
oh that that actually looks like what
i'm expecting it to be
so maybe the problem is in another
variable um
or it prints out the value of x i'm like
that's not right i think it should be
this other value and then i start
digging into the code trying to figure
out
why the value of x is what what the
python interpreter thinks it is
as opposed to what i think it should be
and there's actually a fancier version
of this here's a fancier version
print quote x
end quote comma x okay so what this is
going to do
is that first x which is in quotes
with with a colon after it remember
that's a string
so remember the computer is going to
distinguish between strings and variable
names if there's quotes around it and
remember we
need to use these standard straight
quotes instead of the angle quotes which
if they ever show up on my slides it's
because powerpoint loves turning them
into angle quotes
there is a way to turn it off but then
when you're
typing actual english and the angle
quotes look nice then you don't get
those
anyway so
use the regular straight quotes if
you're using visual studio code
if you're using uh if you're using the
python
editor built-in editor it should just
give you the standard quote shouldn't
give you the angle quotes
anyway so those those straight quotes
that identifies a
character sequence a string of
characters and so
i'm saying print the following string of
characters as is
is literally as i've given it to you so
it will print a
x file by colon and then that second x
after the comma says
you know that's not inside of quotes
that's actually a variable name so it
will go ahead and retrieve the value of
x
so let's say the value of x is currently
3 what this print statement would print
is
x colon 3 and so this is going to be
useful if you're printing out the value
of a bunch of different variables and
it's going to identify you know if i've
got in another place i have print
quote y colon end quote comma y
um i'll see in one place x is 12 y is 15
and so it's useful to to go ahead and
add add in that
extra label
that's going to get printed out when i'm
trying to figure out what the different
variables are being set to
okay another thing to be aware of is
there's actually several different types
of errors that can occur
when we're programming there will refer
to syntax errors
and semantic errors a syntax error
occurs when there's an error in the
grammar
so here i'm trying to take
celsius and then you see i've got that
multiply
divide by 5 and that doesn't make sense
because you can't
multiply something and then divide it
without telling me what you're
multiplying by this is just this is
gibberish all right so this would be the
equivalent of
trying to take a sentence in a language
a human language and
not following the correct grammar rules
so uh
you know with humans the human can
sometimes figure out what it is you're
trying to say but with the computer if
you don't follow the grammar rules if
you don't follow the syntax rules
remember syntax and grammar are
basically synonymous
uh when we're talking about computer
languages here um
if you're not following the grammar or
the syntax rules the computer's just
gonna be like
patrick i have no idea what it is you're
trying to tell me
so i'm just gonna ignore it so that's
the first source of errors
and generally you're going to determine
if you have syntax errors when you
edit your program in the python editor
and you tell it to run
it will immediately tell you hey i
looked through this program you're
telling me to run
and there's a bunch of stuff that are
completely illegal in python these are
not allowed
and those are your syntax errors the
other source of errors
is semantic errors semantic errors occur
when you have a perfectly legal program
but
it's not actually correct so in this
case i'm converting fahrenheit to
celsius
i'm multiplying by 9 i'm dividing by 5.
it turns out i'm also supposed to add 32
to it and i
didn't so this program will run it is
perfectly
legal grammatically correct
syntactically correct python but it's
going to give me the wrong answer
and so in contrast with the syntax
errors which will be discovered by
python as soon as i tell it to run it
will list hey here's a bunch of things
you did wrong these are illegal
the semantically incorrect program is
legal it will run it's just not going to
give you the correct result
and so when that happens you know if
it's a short program you just have to
look over the program and try and figure
out you know
why did i get this number when i thought
i was supposed to get this other number
when you've got a slightly longer
program then you have to go back to what
i said a couple minutes ago about
trying to figure out what those
invisible intermediate results are
and what's going wrong with those so add
in some print statements
to figure out what's going wrong
okay the last thing i wanted to tell you
is that you know i
programming can be very frustrating and
a lot of times when you're first
starting out as a programmer you think
that
i have all these errors in my program
this must be my fault
and i must not be very good at this and
that's
actually not true so it turns out that
if you have bugs in your code you have
bugs or errors in your code
we call errors and code bugs
there's actually a story about why
they're called bugs it's not clear
entirely
this is apocryphal although apparently
this story did happen it's not clear
that this is why they're called bugs but
the story is that back when we had
electromechanical machines
a program was not working and when they
went to try and figure out
why the program was not working there
was a moth stuck
in one of the electromagnetic switches
and therefore they said it was a bug
so that part of the story is actually
true and the person who found the bug
is rear admiral grace hopper if you've
got computer science friends
there's a big conference for women in
computer science named after her
she created one of the most widely used
programming languages back in the day
called cobalt
and the navy actually has
a photograph of the bug that she found
what's less clear is that this is
actually the source of the name
bug but it's an amusing story so i
thought i'd pass it on to all of you
anyway so bugs you have bugs in your
code
you have bugs in your code because you
are a human being
and human beings generally do not write
code correctly the first time
it's a normal occurrence it means that
you are not some sort of a robot
so that's mostly all to the good you
know the tas and i
have bugs in our code so if you have
bugs in your code congratulations
we have bugs in our code there have been
plenty of times where i have sat there
with my computer and wanted to take the
computer and throw out the window
because
i was so sure i had written the code
correctly and it was still wrong
and you know it's just super frustrating
to try and figure out what you did wrong
you're really sure you
you screwed up in fact one of the
very rare occasions that occurred
occurrences is
about five or six years ago i was had
just taken over 108
and every year i would uh when i first
took over
cs108 i would re rewrite the homework
assignments on my own before the
students did to just sort of remind
myself of what the students
were going to be struggling with and i
remember one of the programs
i wrote and it actually ran the first
time
and it was shocking it was amazing it
was the best feeling ever and i
mentioned this because
like that's super unusual that never
happens i still remember that
it was like five or six years ago having
bugs in your program is totally normal
it is not because you are not up to
programming it is because it is part of
the programming experience
and in fact professionals have bugs in
their code and they often have many bugs
in their code
and that's one of the reasons why
programs are constantly updated so you
know if you see
the operating system's being updated
like windows is constantly being updated
um your apps are constantly being
updated sometimes it's adding new
features but more often than not it's
because they had a bug in their code
that they discovered or maybe there's a
security hole in their code because they
didn't think things through carefully
and so uh having bugs in your code is a
perfectly normal part of the experience
i think those of us that become
programmers it's just that
the joy of actually creating a running
program and seeing
something that we thought of in our head
and we've actually created it and it's
up and running
that joy of finally getting it all
running is worth the frustration of
uh having problems with our code until
we get them all debugged
but um you know don't don't feel
that there's something wrong because you
have bugs in your code it is part of
being a human being
again it is something that every
programmer experiences
including the tas and myself and all the
professional programmers
all right in the next video we're going
to extend your programming capability by
adding in
some new structures that will actually
greatly enhance what you're able to do
with your programs
i'll talk to you soon
you